bootleg Cavs show special guest in here
my bro and Elite Chapa always home yes
it's home right here yeah two times
appreciate you coming through man always
uh explain the new jewelry here I
haven't seen this necklace yet this
looks very uh holistic uh this is simply
me meditating in rose gold that's you
yeah
it's uh it's one of my favorite pieces
actually it's fire
yeah meditation man I mean you know I
feel like uh when I first started the
record interviews out of here you came
on pretty early
and I feel like that was kind of like
one of the first interviews where you
like kind of revealed this other side of
yourself that you were discovering like
the more spiritual
um natural some of the diet stuff you're
doing like are you still like on that
path in terms of like take taking care
of what you're putting in your body yeah
even more stronger now
um I don't talk about it as much as I
feel like because I kind of broke the
ground with it already yeah but it's
like I'm even more stronger uh recently
I just tweeted like that I've been on a
been on like a type of fast to where I'm
only eating raw vegetables and fruits
and I've been doing that for like two
months no sex
um
a lot of teas a lot of herbs a lot of
sunlight meditation prayer so it's been
it's been even stronger hyphen now
because I know more right you know so
two months straight just veggies and
fruits and no cooked Foods nothing no
beating no sex no sex wow yeah is that
hard
um I'm getting to the point to where my
discipline is starting to get extremely
sharp it's kind of like um it's a goal
I'm working towards so I feel like when
you put intentions over what the fastest
Ford it kind of helps you stay grounded
and not want to get off schedule because
if you're really trying to work towards
something like you genuinely want that
change you would be disciplined enough
to stay on that course how do you feel
like because a lot of people talk about
those raw diets no cooked food does it
like do you feel the difference man you
feel amazing like you feel you feel so
close to the inner child like how you
felt before you have responsibilities
you know
um if I could be just happy all day and
smiling all day I could be at that point
but I still have to work so I can't
really do it but I still feel like a
child just a child that's working you
know